[Music]
hello there welcome back I'm glad you
could join me today let's just dive
right in and run all the colors across
the screen that you'll need to paint
along with me I have my regular old
canvas here wet and ready to go now
let's grab our trusty two-inch brush
here whack that off a little bit just
beat it like it owes you money we're
gonna get a little damp or yellow snow
here mix that with just another little
dab of our baby water now
well that's just Daniel Sedin happy
little see I remember this is your world
you get to make and break the rules here
sweet baby Jesus
wish I could jump in there and roll
around and all that cascading white
powder yeah just get high and all of
life's splendor God I love cocaine so
much
holy [ __ ] knuckles I am high as a kite
right now okay
let's paint in a few little happy trees
there nothing wrong with making friends
with trees you know what you don't want
to do is eat these paints trust me on
this one
all right I'm gonna whack off from Ken
that's right that feels good
[Laughter]
would you look at that it seems like we
have ourselves a finished painting so
from our family to yours keep your pants
dry your dreams wet and remember hugs
not drugs
[Music]
you